hey hey everyone
[Music]
welcome to the machine learning for
audio study group from hogan face so
this will be the first session
i'm omar san se vero we have bb here
as well hey thank you very much pb for
being here
hello
awesome uh
so we'll go over the logistics in a bit
but let's
first introduce ourselves
so my name is omar san sebiro i'm a
machine learning engineer at coginface
previously i was a software engineer at
google assistant and before that
i had a
community which was focused in teaching
machine learning
in spanish which was called ai learners
a very nice meeting job
[Music]
nice um just a just a quick introduction
about me my name is weber
but you can call me vb
um i am currently a masters uh student
at the university of stuttgart i study
computational linguistics and i work
with um deloitte tax over here um and
you know working on national language
processing plus uh speed synthesis use
cases um i for the
before the pandemic started i was
working with deloitte consulting back in
india uh on strategy and analytics and
uh
i've been um
actively researching for about a year
now
nice to meet you all
awesome that's very cool
uh
so just to give a bit of a super high
level overview of how this study group
is going to be organized is that these
first few weeks it will kick it off with
some of the most basic stuff
so if you don't have any idea about
how machine learning is used for audio
these first three sessions will be
perfect for you after that we'll focus a
bit more on reading papers written
resources discussing things
that we as a community decide and then
we can even invite people from
the hook and face team or speech brain
or other
open source libraries or people in the
industry doing a cool research on the
topic
to give some presentations
so every week we'll be sharing we'll be
having uh sorry every session is at the
beginning it will be every week then it
will be every two weeks
there will be some related resources so
those could be papers those could be
blog posts those could be a youtube
videos
during each session you can ask
so let me show you some of the resources
so if you're watching this in youtube
which is the only place where you can be
watching this
hey here in the description you can
already find a link to the forum so the
forum is the perfect place to ask
questions uh
so there is this thread which is ml for
audio study group again the link is in
the description for youtube and you can
ask questions here
at the end of the short presentations
we'll go over these questions and we'll
be
answering them
the second one is the github repo
so this is kind of our compilation of
all of the resources in a single place
including a schedule
with which are the topics that we are
going to see which are the recommended
resources and later on we'll be adding
like more supplementary resources so
right now we have
some slides
uh
we have some research papers uh toolkits
and demos but we'll be sharing more as
as this study group
progresses
and finally we also have a
a discord
so this is the discord so if you are
from discord
everyone
and
you can find a channel which is ml for
audio study group and this will be the
place between the different sessions in
which you can come you can uh do a bit
more of an informal discussion or your
brainstorm ideas or like ask like how to
do certain things if you prefer to not
bust in the form but at least for the
session of today we are going to be
focusing entirely uh in the questions
asked in the forum so please if you have
any questions in the next
30 minutes in the next hour feel free to
come here and ask your questions here
yeah that's pretty much
in terms of
what are the expectations
really like this is a community-led
effort so feel free to make it
whatever you want it to become so
if you want to focus in papers if you
want to focus in on certain areas if you
want to focus in music for example feel
free to propose papers to propose ideas
to discuss these kind of topics
okay so the timeline is that today we'll
do like a kickoff session we'll kick it
off like very very like easy so it won't
be like super complicated stuff
uh
next week we'll do a like a automatic
speech recognition uh we'll explain in a
minute what that is and also like very
basics of what audio is and what uh
what are the challenges in machine
learning and then uh
in january to kick off next year we'll
talk about dts that's a text-to-speech
and after that we'll decide as a group
what papers we want to do if we want to
invite speakers if you want to do like a
deep dive into any specific task
having said that i think maybe we
will continue the presentation
perfect um
all right
my screen's available right
yeah okay
all right awesome so um what we're gonna
do for the next 20 to 25 minutes is um
is essentially
go over like the two broad um
applications that we come across within
spoken language understanding within
speech right
one of them is um
speech recognition and the other one is
text to speech um and we'll essentially
superficially understand what they are
um why is it that we should be um you
know uh more cognizant of what's
happening over there um and basically
just get an intuition of um
what all is it that we
um that we will be sort of covering or
tackling um in the weeks to come
um
with that um
this is like in like a very exciting
time for spoken language uh processing
in general right um we now have um very
strong
and very capable uh speech recognizers
in our phone
which is um siri google assistant um you
know alexa
we have
um really nice um
text-to-speech models um like for
example every time you you go to a
google translate you're able to write in
english and then be able to get text
then be able to
get speech out in you know spanish or in
german or whatever the language may be
and all of this is uh happening all
because of um neural networks and um
we'll get to how this was done before
but right now pretty much all sorts of
um automatic speech recognition or um
um text-to-speech is done using
end-to-end um neural networks so
everything that you see is um is
basically a neural network and in the
weeks to come we will sort of unpack
this a bit more uh through papers um or
through um sessions like these
um
so um let's first understand the um the
overall um the overarching sort of field
a bit more um so
in general what what exactly is a is a
dialogue right like a dialogue is is
something which when i say something
right so i say hey do you want to grab
um a dinner then someone says um
something like um sure um where do you
want to grab a dinner and then i
understand that and i say um does the
city center look nice to you right and
um so all this all this
back and forth between me saying
something and someone responding to it
is basically a dialogue right and us
humans are really nice at uh
understanding dialogues um however the
machines are not for a for a machine or
for an algorithm to understand that they
need to have um a lot more things in
place um than just um
um than just
you know um uh just one one model
understanding everything right um a
simple example of this is um when you
ask alexa about the weather so you have
to say hey alexa what's the weather like
today
right and then alexa would uh would tell
you okay it's it's snowing and it will
continue to snow till 5 pm for example
but um then you
if you ask anything else you need to
again say hey alexa and then say the
next thing so there's no like dialogue
or there's no conversation that's
happening per se right and that's one of
the limitations that we'll discuss later
on the spell um
in the in the
um in the in the purest sense
um
but yeah like there are certain design
considerations that we have to take into
consideration so um a thing like um
alexa when you can ask one thing to it
at a time works quite well because we
typically have just single questions
what is this can you play that um should
i should i carry an umbrella and so on
and so forth right um then there can
also be um you know
purely likes you know translation based
tasks wherein like you
say something in one language and you
expect the um
the model to return output in in another
language it can be text it can be
um speech right so um all that we're
trying to sort of um portray over here
is that um there are like multiple
design considerations that go into
creating um a conversational agent um
a task which is as simple as you know
just talking for us is very difficult
for
um
for the machines if i may call it
um and an example of this is is
something that you see on the screen
right
so um say for example let's take uh mary
here talking on the phone
and
she is saying something
um
which the the phone perceives as
waveforms right and then the phone um
and then the phone performs something
called automatic speech recognition
which takes the waveform and converts it
into text
right um so
now we have some natural language right
and then this natural language goes into
um
goes into a spoken language
understanding unit which takes the text
above so
from leaving from downtown which you see
over here um we understand that okay so
um you know she's leaving from downtown
right um and there is like some sort of
uh depart time which is 1 pm and there
is some sort of um
arrive time which is 1 pm again right
and there is some sort of a probability
associated to all of this
um
then there is
a dialogue state tracker which basically
tracks all of this through time so
mary would would essentially be having a
lot of conversations through and through
uh or like a lot of back and forth with
whoever she's talking with um in this
case it's a bot um and and you know so
we will keep a track of all that we've
spoken with her in like a dialogue state
tracker right
um and then we'll have certain policies
so um you know
um she's saying for example leaving from
uh downtown um then we can we can we can
basically have some sort of a activity
or some sort of an action to that um in
this case the dialogue policy
um chosen was to confirm whether
um it is downtown or not right and then
this policy goes into the natural
language generation part which which
says um which generates the text called
from downtown is that right
and then that text is converted into
speech
right so
so um this is
again like all of these are our
individual
um components of of of of an entire
conversational agent um however
you have to realize that it's not just
that a model understands the speech and
it
you know uh returns back some speech
it's it's much more complicated than
that and all of these um have different
levels of um of you know accuracies
right now some work quite well some
don't work uh that well some are end to
end and some are more rule based for
example a dialogue bollis policy in a
more specific domain would almost always
be um
you know rule based um and so on and so
forth
um so
now that we've sort of covered like an
um like a broad overview of what
is it that that um that that the overall
um sort of conversational setup entails
let's look at um two key
individual parts so first we'll cover
speech recognition and then we will go
over to uh text to speech again this is
at like a 10 000 feet level just to give
you an intuition of
um what's happening
um
so let's talk about speech recognition
right um simplistically
let's assume like a very simple scenario
um wherein we just want to recognize two
words yes and no
right um now if if um we from our
machine learning background if we were
to think of a
um think of an example of recognizing
yes and no um it's a very simple
classification problem right you
give it some sort of a waveform you give
your model some sort of a waveform and
then you
um
expect the model to through through
different different patterns understand
um
which is a yes and which is a no
right
that's quite simple however in uh in
real life it's much more complicated
than that we just in english alone we
have more than 64 000 words that we use
um
uh more often than not right
um and then
while
um while we talk about just the words um
different speakers have different ways
of talking about things so to give you
an example i am from india i have a
certain accent when i um speak in
english similarly someone who's who's
from um the uk will have certain accent
while they're speaking um as opposed to
someone who's from the from the us right
so uh the accent the pitch differs um in
in general right um
more specifically um the way i say one
word differs from the way i say
uh something continuously um and this is
uh basically the procedure we we will
get to that in the in the q a because
there is a question around that uh but
just to give you an example of this if i
was to just say um alex
just the just the word alex right now
alex is an isolated word and the way i
say it is much different than if i put
it in a sentence so if i put it in in a
sentence like hey alex do you want to
grab the pear or something like that
um then like my emphasis on the word
alex is much less than when i was when i
just said it as an isolated word right
um
and and so this is just to just to um
tell you the
the differences
um that we have in the speech itself
right so there are a lot more factors
than just converting a waveform to
um
to text when it comes to speech
recognition
um
but yeah we we'll get to how we solve
that um later on
um
yeah and
this is the most simplest form of um
this is what like asr is like you have
some some form of a asr up sorry some
form of a waveform and then you convert
it um to its time for lunge for example
in this case this this waveform actually
corresponds to its time for lunch
um
and the way
we we do it um or like the most basic
architecture that um exists in the
neural network world um is is an is an
encoder decoder um
setup so you have the waveform and then
you
extract features using um a male
spectrogram
and then you um you you feed it into an
encoder and then like
um specific sequences or like specific
parts of this um of this particular
waves um waveforms are then like
converted into
um a character and then all of those are
pulled together to
eventually uh give you a sentence right
so um
there's there's like a lot more that
that that goes into actually
um
building these um these end-to-end
models but this is the most simplest uh
setup
um that exists out there right and we
will cover these um
these this specific architecture in more
detail uh next week uh but i just wanted
to want for you all to get a sense of
what what exactly is happening right so
essentially this is a sequence to
sequence task right so you have sequence
which is a waveform you take that you
convert it into a male spectrogram
you pass it into an end-to-end model and
it um gives you text at the end right um
one thing to note is that like waveforms
are much more dense
as compared to text so for example this
is it's time for lunch this is much more
dense than just four tokens saying it's
time for lunch right so we we also like
do some sort of sub sampling
um and like
some sort of feature selection as well
um in in between uh in end-to-end models
that happen automatically um but but
yeah i just wanted to
um emphasize more on this
um so up until like up until now we've
sort of understood what asr is right so
asr is that is the task of taking a
waveform and converting it into a text
right
um and we've understood like a very
basic
model um
which does this right a very simple
encoder decoder approach which does this
um
um end to end um but how well have we
done um so far uh so one of the one of
the most um
most simplest metrics that we use
within the
asr world are called is called word
error rate so what is a word error rate
so word error rate is basically the
percentage of words that were
misrecognized by the model so if the
waveform says it's time for lunch
but the
but the model says
it um like it's time for
dinner for example i mean it will never
happen but let's take this example then
there is one word which is which is
wrong
so the most simplest word error rate um
like like the word error rate for this
sentence would be 25 percent because the
model got
one out of four tokens wrong right so
you get like a 25 word error rate
um
right now if you if you see like
especially for like english we've
reached a word rate of 1.4 percent
um which means that
um roughly like every one
word of hundred um words that the that
the model transcribes
um would be wrong in my opinion that's
that's like fantastic um like
we humans make a lot of mistakes as well
while we while we converse um and like
um
you know understand stuff as well and we
sometimes ask for what did you mean by
that what did you mean by this and so on
and so forth so um i think i think one
1.4 percent is is um quite nice
um in that retrospect and there are like
different different um data sets um that
are out there um so there's a
switchboard data site which is quite old
and it's basically conversation between
strangers on the telephone there's call
home there's social linguistic
interviews and so on and so forth and
you can see like
um
like like the first one which is libra
speech um it's it's the clean variant of
it which means that
this was recorded in a studio so like
you you had the perfect microphone
quality you had the perfect environment
and so on and so forth you did not have
someone uh banging on your door
while you're while you're trying to um
understand stuff or you did not have
like you know
a microphone like what i have on um like
it it's those were just pristine
conditions so of course um you know
garbage and garbage out if your quality
of data is great then your model is
great but if your quality of input data
is not that great then
yeah um the order rate as you can see
down below starts decreasing
considerably so especially for like um
shine five dinner parties data set
wherein like
the
uh the
the audio was recorded from
at a dinner party but and and and also
from um
distant microphones across the rooms um
the word error rate is 81.3 which means
like the model
essentially almost always gets it wrong
right so this is basically to
to sort of tell you that um we do like
we do quite great when the conditions
are pristine but when it comes to real
life scenarios we're not there yet
um
similarly for
um for mandarin um over there we used
character error rate um
as well and like um
over there at 6.7 percent and i don't
know if any one of you know mandarin but
like mandarin has um like just like in
terms of prosodic features has has a
has a very difficult
um
has very different uh difficult speech
intonations when you actually speak it
so
wireless humans can understand it um for
a model to understand those features in
a very short time that too with a very
short corpus um or like very small
corpus is um is still a difficult task
um
so all of this was just to was just to
set the context of um or the fact that
this is
still not a solved problem
um like so
there are still quite a lot of um
quite a lot of uh things that that can
be done in the asr setup um to make it
more um
more beneficial um for others and one of
the things which which um a lot of
people in my um
research group work on is specifically
about um
you know using different uh like
creating systems for different languages
as well um so
um what about languages which which have
little to no um data available like
english has a lot of data right
similarly for example german has a lot
of data um
french has a lot of data but what about
um you know
some obscure language um
from india for example um
and and and and so on we don't have um
zero shot systems available we don't
have like few short systems available
for speech recognition so in general
there's there's like a lot of things um
that um that
um and
that you can do when it comes to speech
recognition uh and you know more
specifically when it comes to embedded
uh speech recognition as well like like
the ones that happen on your phone
um and so on
um so that was like i hope you you you
got a quick picture of what does what
happens when it
when we talk about speech recognition
and you got a quick sense of
where we are when it comes to um
sort of speech recognition in general uh
and and like uh what where exactly is it
that the gap still exists um and um yeah
we didn't talk about what we can do
about it uh but but hopefully that's
what we'll discuss um in the
in the times to come
um
and uh
so let's move over to speech synthesis
now
um so what is speed synthesis um
speech synthesis and it's in its most
simplistic form is to you know produce
speech from a text right so if i give
the text um hey my name is webhoof
i get an output from the model which
says um hey my name is pepper
so it converts text into uh speech and
as we saw from the example before um
this is definitely used
um
for
um you know in like personal assistants
so so like uh siri
um google assistant and um you know um
cortana and so on and so forth uh this
can also be used for like announcements
so like the announcements that you
probably hear at train stations
um can be used definitely for that um it
can be used um for like multitudes of
other uh other things also like um with
the advent of deep fake and so on and so
forth you can sort of get um different
voice
um
so like voiceovers and so on and so
forth um as well um but just in general
like the just the ability to be able to
um convert text into into speech is is
text to speech
um
and and um the way this this um this
again works is again from like a
end-to-end uh neural network um approach
and like um the basic idea is that you
take some speech um
you know which is um in between say five
to 50 hours um
it's it's good if it's from one speaker
but again we have good multi-speaker
models as well um then you transcribe
them meaning you listen the listen to
the
to the audio and then you transcribe it
into text
um and and and then you feed it um into
um into an end-to-end model um
in the previous days there was a lot
more that you would do so for example
you would you would understand what all
um phones
does it have which is like essentially
mapping each and every character
um uh to like a phoneme using like an
e-bar chart and like what not um now
like with the end-to-end systems you
don't have to do that you basically just
give the
um
the audio along with the transcriptions
and it works um quite well um in general
and um so
um text-to-speech is not like completely
end-to-end so like we first take
um we sorry we first take take the text
and then we convert it into a
male spectrogram and then we take that
mel spectrogram and pass it into a
vocoder which converts it into
um into
speech
so there are like two fold steps that
happen in in textures in text-to-speech
um
and
the tts part the text-to-speech part is
uh typically this this one and this one
the second one is vocoder so we have
couple of models for it like heapigan
um mel gan and so on and so forth we
will be
at least talking about those briefly um
in the january 4th session
um for sure um and like of course the
the pipeline to take text and convert it
into
um
into my spectrogram as well
um so this is actually
a rather complex um architecture but i
just wanted to sort of talk about the
end to end
part of of text to speech um this is a
tacotron
2 um
model which was from google
um i think this was released back in
2019 or 2018 and um
like what you can see over here is that
there is like the input text then you
create and create a character embedding
out of it and then you have lstms and
then you have an attention between the
encoder output and uh
decoder and then you have this
um this one thing called stop token
which essentially predicts whether
wherever you're at right now uh whether
it's okay to stop the sentence here or
not so
if you're at
if if i want the model to
create the male spectrogram of
um
my name is weber
so
at webhub it sort of checks
whether it's it's it's good enough for
me to stop right now and uh switch to a
new new sentence or not right
um and you can see over here that we we
get the male spectrogram over here and
then we we have some form of like
vocoder in this one they use wavenet but
effectively you can use any
uh which converts the male spectrogram
to the waveform
and um as you can as you would have
realized by now that if you draw
parallels from asr um it's pretty much
the same thing it is also a sequence to
sequence model um except just the other
way around right
in that one you you have a wave and then
you convert it into a metal spectrogram
and then you feed it into the model and
then get text out and this one you do it
the other way around you have text you
create my spectrogram and then you um
get the wave from waveform out
um just a quick quick note over here all
of these like all of these slides were
either taken from
a stanford speech language understanding
course or from the um
slp book and i've marked the link um on
the bottom right so in case you're going
through these sites later on you can
quickly just click on that and just
understand the overall
approach that i just explained in more
detail as well
um
so um there are like
so with that we can we can sort of
finish the text to speech part um
i think one of the things that i that i
wanted to cover um real quick over here
is like how exactly do we do we measure
um the efficiency of a text-to-speech
model um the answer is that there are no
like there's no right way to do that um
typically a text-to-speech model is um
evaluated using a mos survey um so like
you get like a mean score
so like you take say 10 20
test sentences you create you pass it
through the model you get the
corresponding waveform um or the audio
and then you have say 40 50 people
listen to it and give it a rating on a
scale of zero to five as to how
intelligible was it how how great was it
and so on and so forth um
and then you get a
um then you get like a mean score and
then you sort of compare
but there's no like score like word
error rate as such for um text-to-speech
um or at least none that i have come
across so far
let me put it that way
um
yeah and and um then there are like
multiple um applications
um
in general
like this is beyond text to speech uh
beyond asl asr just just overall in
terms of the applications of speech
right there are like multiple of those
like how can i extract information from
speech right so how can i separate say
for example
um there was a question in the forums
about it how can i separate um
us like
the singer singing from the acoustics
right how can i separate that from um
from the acoustics and um um you know
how how can i um uh
like what can i do next with that uh can
i understand the emotion of a person can
i understand
um you know whether a particular thing
is toxic or not can i identify a speaker
in in a room full of say five six people
um can identify who's speaking at this
point of time right um
and uh can i move from like an
end-to-end dialogue system uh based
approach can i make um
you know reservations
um
by talking to a board i i think google
had a really nice demo for it um a
couple years back wherein like they they
basically have two bots talking to each
other and make
make a reservation and um uh what was
great about it was that the models
actually understood um
the
the conversation so well that they also
added like some you know um
prosthetic features in the speech itself
which was you know adding filler words
like um
but um does this work and so on and so
forth
and um i think that was pretty cool um
we're not there yet but but you know who
knows maybe in a year or two we're there
um
then we get to the last slide uh which
is what other speech related tasks are
there like we we spent a lot of time
understanding speech recognition and um
uh you know text to speech um and that's
because those are the two most im sort
of most
um heavily you know uh time consuming
tasks out there that we typically uh
come across um and and are are an active
um
research area um
uh but there are like certain other
tasks as well for example the most
simplest one that i could think of was
like wake world right how do you like
when i say something um how do i
uh identify when am i saying um
a short phrase or a word which um uh
which lets my alexa know that um i am
asking something to her right so um or
do it
um then there is you know speaker
diarization which is understanding or
like determining who spoke when right um
in in a multi-speaker um audio recording
uh then there's speaker recognition um
which is
um just identifying who the speaker is
so if i'm saying and if if omar is
saying something then just
segregating um when is bb talking and
when is omar talking and so on and so
forth um then there's language
identification this is used in like
translation systems a lot um especially
like end-to-end translation systems just
understanding which language is someone
talking in or like identifying that and
then like using that information as a
metadata to the to the to the
translation model and then
um
you know passing that um
information further
um
so um with that i hope you got like a
quick sense of of um what these what
these tasks are what they can do and um
um you know
how they how they sort of work i wanted
to quickly uh jump in
um
and show you like a quick demo
um do we have time for that omar or do
we want to take oh yeah
go ahead
all right
so
let me just quickly
oh my god
that's the wrong one
i hope that this opened soon
uh
yeah sorry my laptop's acting up a bit
um
let me just search this
so on the on the github repo itself i
put in like three uh hugging face um
spaces i think let's quickly see um one
text to speech example and then like one
asr example
um so just a quick refresher um text to
speech is
um is something wherein we take an input
text and create um some sort of speech
out of it um so let's say hey
i am part of a
hf
and then we hit submit
um
one thing like while this runs and and
you will observe right now is that um
typically these models are there is like
it took five seconds for the model to
create this
this speech but five seconds is also too
much specifically when it comes to a lot
of dialogue based systems so there is
also another active area of research on
like how to reduce this time this
influence time as well
yeah i don't know if you can hear it um
were you able to hear it
no
no but i think i i think it's okay uh
yeah i would suggest people to just i
put the link in the in the comments so
feel free to
try out the the demos directly yourself
yeah perfect um and i just want to give
a quick example of
um why we need better text to speed
systems um over here with this example
if you actually just type this in
in the space and just um
hear the the audio you'll see that the
the model messes up big time at hf um
demo
um just because it does not know whether
it is
whether it's supposed to to pronounce
this
as hf
or as you know
like the sound
hf you know
and it it basically does something in
between um in the output audio so
there's still a lot more for us to do
when it comes to creating good
text-to-speech
systems
now let's take
another quick example of um asr and then
we can head to questions
um
i am not going to record anything
oh wait where are the demo files
huh
weird um
i don't know why the why the demo files
are not showing up here anymore maybe
this got updated from yesterday um but
you can you can basically try this with
your own mic just hit record and um see
what the
wait this is speech translation maybe i
i linked the wrong
repo here
but what this one all right i linked the
wrong one but this one what what this
does is that you give it speech in in in
one language say for example
english
oh sorry um
like say i say something in english then
it performs like language identification
and then whatever language i give it for
example swedish it will convert that and
um
pass me
the translation of it uh in the speech
form as well as in the in the written
form um so do check this out i will link
the asr demo
um in the repo and and post it on the
forums as well later on uh but yeah just
wanted for you to have
two
points of things that you can just try
out uh what we just spoke of um just
right now
so yeah with that i
will stop sharing
awesome
cool uh
yeah so we'll go to the questions in a
minute uh
but just as a quick overview of what
will be happening uh
probably like some of the technical
concepts that they
mentioned maybe you don't know them for
example a
spec program i think that's like a good
example
uh so we'll go a bit more in detail on
what it really is i think the idea of
this initial session was just to give
like a high level overview of the field
but then next week we'll do
an intro to audio so what's a sample
rate
what's a spec program and how the data
is processed for machine learning
and then we'll do a deep dive into how
automatic speech recognition is
having said that
i think we can go to
to the questions
so the first question which was by me it
was more to kick things off and i think
maybe already answered quite well in his
presentation
let me criticize is
what other kind of tasks can be solved
in the auto domain but i think this was
all very well
okay so let's go first with this one
from ambitness
are there any works that directly
perform modeling on raw audio signals
itself
without using text as an intermediate
medium
how common is it compared to doing
automatic speech recognition and then
running regular ndp models on text
um right so um it's it's actually much
more uh common now um especially from
like 2019 onward and i'll just um link a
um
link
to this
um
um to this paper um from google i think
this was this was back from um this is
back from 2019 and um there's this uh
there's this block that they that they
posted about uh trans translate sean
um it's it's a bit of a mouthful um but
they basically take speech and directly
convert speech into um
speech
in the target language right so they
take speech in one language and convert
it into speech in another language just
in general um speech is much more rich
right um so
there is like this whole concept of
prosidy which comes into speech which is
um if if say i'm saying something let's
take for example a question answer thing
right so if say i say hey who ate my
cake
right so he had a had a slightly higher
pitch in donation
uh and then there there can be a
response to it saying um
mary ate your
um cake which is a informational focus
and there's like a normal response to it
but what if this was something like no
um
john ate your cake right so there is
more emphasis on john and there is more
like there is a higher pitch um in no so
just that
um just from like a waveform standpoint
just from the way we we speak there's so
much like so much more richness that is
available uh as opposed to you know just
like a one-dimensional text vector uh uh
out there um that it makes more sense to
do stuff on speech it's now
um with the advent of you know as much
like practically infinite compute out
there um it's it's much more easy to
build your model straight from speech um
so so my answer would be yes
and i can um you know once i respond to
the to this on the forums i can also
link couple of papers that will
help you understand
that better
listen thanks a lot there is another
question which is unrelated to this one
which is
if it's possible to build a model
or to solve this task
of counting a filler words such as um
and that kind of
words
yeah would you model this
i i think there are like multiple ways
to do that and um i think the most
simplest one that that i could think of
um doing that was
um
like first let's let's let's think of
this as as the most
um let's think of this as a
classification task right so your your
speed signal um
let's assume that you have 10
milliseconds of windows uh of your speed
signal which you input to your model and
then the model gives you some sort of
character um if you go back to the asr
domain right and um
like assume that uh all filler words
have like certain disfluency associated
to them right so um say for example if
i'm saying something
let's take an example of um
i am going to the cafe and i'm gonna
offer uh and i'm gonna order a
cappuccino let's take this sentence as
an example so if i was to say it
fluently i would say i'm going to go to
the cafe and i'm going to offer
um i'm going to order um an espresso for
example but if i was to
put some filler words it would be i'm
going to the cafe
and i am um
going to order
um
an
espresso so you can see that there was
there were disjoints in the entire
speech right so one of the most simplest
ways to just like look for these
disjoints
in the speech right and then you um and
then you sort of
take those those disc joints and you um
you just like classify a model on it
right so uh then it becomes like a very
simple like from a male spectrogram of
of the speech you you basically just um
search for whether or not that disjoint
is there
in the spectrogram itself right and um i
think you you you basically just need to
like in in in terms of learning what to
do with that you just basically need to
learn
um um how to convert male spectr like
how to
take features from male spectrogram and
just
create a very small data set um again
like you can create it yourself or you
can just use one of those um
conversational datasets that we were
talking about they have a lot of filler
words just take one or two hours of
recordings transcribe it
because
in your case you just have to transcribe
whether there is a filler word in this
particular window or not so it's a yes
or no thing it's not as complicated as
knowing everything
uh out there and you can do it um
that way there's actually um a very
interesting paper um that
omar and i were discussing this morning
um let me see if i can find the link to
it
um
it is this one i'm just sending it to
omar once more so that he can put it up
um and
yeah if you know um if it's there's like
an entire like
part of like how they identify um
how they identify filler words in this
and if you just like zoom in a little
bit more on the figure one uh on the
right side yeah so like you face you you
first do like a filler word segmentation
right and then you identify where they
are and they use the same disk fluency
to do it and then you can basically
replace them with static noise and so on
and so forth in your case once you
identify that you can
increase the count of filler words
so this might help
again there are like multiple ways to
solve it this was the most simplest one
that i could think of
awesome thanks a lot
a quick post there was one question from
youtube just
to answer that money the question from
ali is what is the slp resource again
just to answer a from the github
repository
it's the speech and language processing
it's actually a super
nice book
it's like for special language
processing but it really is like a super
nice introduction also to a lot of nlp
related stuff
and we recommend specifically the
chapter 26
which you can see here at the bottom so
it's for asl and dts
and this one a part of it is actually
one of the recommended resources for the
next session uh the sections 26.1 to
26.5
awesome
again i remember that we'll try to
prioritize questions that are in the
forum so please feel free to ask
questions here
yeah so there's this question from
sharma is out of curiosity is it
possible to separate words and music
from a song audio
um
first of all i want to say like thank
you so much for asking that because i um
found a new technique
while i was researching the
um
answer to it and i'm just sending the
link over for that um you can
effectively like if you have enough
um
enough speech or like enough music in
your context and you can run something
like um um like an
pca or like some sort of a decomposition
right so it can be an svd um
in the case of the in the case of the
um uh in the case of the
paper that you see over here they used
rpca which is like a modified principle
uh component analysis and um
they use that to separate the acoustics
from the
from what the speaker was actually
saying but in general this this becomes
like um
like more of a
you know
um separation task and this is very much
doable provided you have enough data um
for it um i think one thing that you
would have to
take into consideration is when you're
building something like this you will
need to have the same domain of data so
say for example if you're dealing with
um
country music then the way country the
way you would separate country music
would be much different than say for
example heavy metal right just because
of like separate um acoustics out there
we will be sharing these resources later
on yeah
yeah everything will be in discord and
also in the forum i will be sharing all
of this
and also like again if you have if you
want to further discuss this like in
more detail
rather than a question answering format
more or less a discussion feel free to
use this chord to do that as well
okay
we have only two minutes we have two
three questions more so let's try to
briefly
answer these ones
so this one from alexei turkey is
a significant portion of information is
lost when we transform speech to text
there's templating brave volume etc
all these aspects may be helpful on
downstream tasks as it would seem
and for example if we want to determine
emotion being expressed
things like pitch volume and tempo can
be useful
er than the content itself
so
for example considering utilizing may
instead of meaning in my previous
sentence i think it makes sense to
consider using non-verbal information
for asl sorry automatic speech
understanding and generation and the
question is is that the thing
yes um this is the thing and um like if
you were to ask this say in 2017 then
this was not a thing um we were still
converting everything to
uh to text and doing stuff like that um
uh but like now this is this is very
much a thing um you can actually um look
for an example like this with um with
siri at least i've tried this um if you
talk to siri
um in a elevated pitch you know with
like an angry
um
voice uh then the city's response would
be would be um actually like really
really mellowed out like the pitch at
with which like it she would or like i
don't know which
uh gender you would be using but like
whichever one you're using would be
quite mellowed out um and if you ask it
with like a happy
uh way like the like the overall pitch
with which it responds actually changes
a lot and uh i think that's that's a
fantastic example of all that you're
saying
uh and um you know
seeing that um in real life
awesome thanks
uh
i think we will skip this one because
it's like super specific to the reading
if that's okay and we will answer
directly in the firm i think that might
work better
yeah uh and the next question is there
are code up available where we can try
speech recognition on beginner
intermediate level uh we don't have one
right now but i think the idea will be
for the next session to have one of
these uh
yeah uh yeah so we'll update on that
so
yeah there will definitely be one um in
the next session for sure wherein you
can just quickly take a
um
[Music]
hugging phase model or a speech brain
model and just um
um try it out yeah
awesome yeah in in case uh just to share
a couple of quick resources uh
maybe
like if you want to go to the huge face
website if you've never done it you can
go to models here at the top
and then you can go at the left and
click this plus 12
and then you can select all of the
different audio tasks here for example
you can search for automatic speech
recognition and you will see that on the
code we have like 800 asr models
and you can even click here and we have
like widgets here this one is wave to
back to from facebook and you can trade
directly here
so we'll show you how to use this in
python it's like
very easy to use
both a from an api perspective and from
a library perspective you can try both
and this is using the transformers
library but we also have integrations
with other ones so for example if you
don't know speech brain
speech brain is like a
very nice library for different audio
related stuff so for example they have a
audio source sorry this is a speech
enhancement model so that removes noise
but there's also like
audio source separation models and other
models that you can also try it directly
in the browser so that's a
very nice and deliberate this is speech
frame in case you didn't know it
okay so i think we have a
one
last question one second
yeah so the question is
if the model generates longer
transcription than ground truth and
every word is wrong
would the word error rate be greater
than 100 percent
uh and i think the answer is yes
maybe let's show you the formula for
word error rate so this is wikipedia
which is a great source
so here uh
the end the number you divide is the
number of words in the reference uh so
that's like ground truth right so on the
top you might end up having like like if
there were only 10 words and at the end
you generated like 10 000 words in the
transcription uh the word level rate
would be much higher than 100 percent
uh is that right maybe
yeah yes right yeah
awesome
yeah so there's this question which
framework of speech recognition gives
free training model that
we can do fine tuning easily for domain
adaptation
yeah i think i mean um you can pretty
much use uh any speech print models for
it they have
plenty models
um
available for asr
um and you should be able to
just
find finding those uh those
so
um i i think maybe uh if it makes sense
then i can um
go through the tutorials and uh there is
one which which does this and i can
probably link it in the forums again
um so you so you will know that but just
to answer speech brain
yes that's good
okay let's answer this last question and
then i think we
will finish this session is
what's the state of the art for speaker
recognition
i don't remember that actually but i
will i will get back to you on this it's
um it's much higher uh than you think uh
it is like um and there are at least i
remember there are some models which i
which i saw in a in a paper um last week
i will look through that and i will and
i will find it uh but
if i'm not completely wrong speech brain
should have something yeah yeah
speech brain like
like this speech classification problems
and there it has like a speaker
identification models uh
i don't know if it's the state of the
art to be honest the models are also on
the hub so you can also
search here uh
i think it's this one yeah speaker
verification
there must be another one for this but i
think this should work and this one that
you can already use
but yeah i don't know what's the state
of the art
one resource that might be useful but i
don't know what's the data set normally
used for this specific task
but you can search in papers with code
data sets
and for example for asl
we use library speech right so you can
always click here click the data set
click the benchmark and there you will
see a comparison of different models of
the speech too and like different
architectures and you can even like
click it and find which are the papers
which are the results presented by this
paper so for example
here conformer plus wave to back to the
speak augmented based noisy student
training with every light
that's long but yeah anyways the magic
value was 1.4 worth error rate so this
is a good resource if you're interested
in one specific task it might be easy to
search here as well
awesome i don't think we have any other
questions uh
feel free to join this card if you don't
know
where discord is the link is right in
the video description you can also come
here there's the ml for audio study
group
here is the full name at the top
feel free to join feel free to ask any
questions
see you next week
just as a quick reminder there are like
two recommended resources for next week
the first one is from fastayai
this is a a cola a jupiter notebook
that gives a very
very like introduction
to the topic it's very basic uh
there might be some like very technical
concepts don't focus too much in those
the idea is to get a high level
understanding of it
is not to become an expert in speech
processing in signal uh through in
speech signal processing
but just to get a better understanding
on what's the data we are working with
and yeah the second
resource is the book as we were sharing
before
uh that's uh
this chapter 26 and this is all free
this
everything is open
and yeah ideally uh try to read these
two resources beforehand try to post any
questions you have directly and we'll
open a new topic later today so you will
be able to ask questions there
and just as today we'll spend like 20
minutes answering some of those
having said that thanks vivi for the
awesome presentation and
thank you everyone that uh join and this
there will be the video in youtube uh
the presentation will also be shared
on let's see it's already on it's
already on oh yeah
awesome so you can find the presentation
here as well
yeah and once again thank you everyone
all right bye-bye